okay one other really quick note here
at Trump's previous rally in Ohio
we had this crazy thing where he starts
playing dramatic music while he talks
about how terrible things are in the U.S
and a lot of people in the crowd did a
one-finger salute and we didn't know
whether the idea was that it's a Nazi
salute except they're doing one finger
instead of the flat hand so it doesn't
look the same or whether it's a q Anon
salute because Q Anon has this WW1 you
know you guys know the thing okay so it
turns out it's a q Anon thing and the
Trump people
caught wind that it doesn't look great
for there to be Q Anon salutes happening
at Trump rallies so when they started
playing the dramatic conspiracy music at
Trump's latest rally in Wilmington North
Carolina security actually went through
the crowd uh telling people to put down
their hands it was very very interesting
and there's a couple of different posts
about this and this one you see
one guy with an American flag shirt with
the one finger thing and then you see
these security people going through the
crowd and it was widely reported that
they were telling all those people to
put their hands down to put their
fingers down that they didn't want to
see that we actually have a video of
this happening as well and this is what
Donald Trump is speaking and you see
some of these people with their fingers
up and then you start to see the
security people go through the crowd and
saying put your finger down put your
finger down you see these people go
through finger hands down hands down
hands down a bunch of them and then the
fingers come down they clearly have
realized that it doesn't look
particularly good for this to be
happening because it's a q Anon salute
now what's really funny is initially the
reaction was they're just saying we're
number one of course that doesn't make
any sense because they're saying we're
number one supposedly during the part of
the speech where Trump talks about how
terrible the country has become
so why would they decide to say we're
number one while Trump is talking about
our airports are terrible
you know crime is rampant the economy is
terrible our leaders everything's
terrible oh yeah we're number one that
doesn't make any sense
so then now they're implicitly admitting
that it is not a salute that is just
we're number one because security goes
through the crowd when the fingers come
up and they say you got to put those
fingers down just a little note for
everybody on that particular issue
it was never the truth that they
believed that they were just saying
we're number one ever ever it's a q Anon
salute it looks bad and now they're
having their literal Brown Shirts it's
an extra security force that wears Brown
Shirts go through the crowd and say put
the fingers down these rallies have
become completely dystopian